hoje vou contar pra vocês sobre a guerra
está acontecendo na síria
na síria a síria é um país localizado no
oriente médio o que o que está
acontecendo na síria na síria há vários
grupos religiosos com os ortodoxos e e
os islâmicos e alguns lá alguns desses
grupos
eles são as extremistas mais radicais
então eles tentam impor a sua religião é
lhe as suas culturas na síria 18,5
milhões de habitantes de nome oficial é
república árabe da síria e aqui embaixo
tem a sua bandeira
o que está acontecendo na síria desde 26
de janeiro de 2011 país está em guerra
civil
o que quer dizer que ele está que nunca
foi um país tão calmo ele sempre teve
algum conflito aqui algum conflito ali
estudiosos acredita que demoraria 20 a
30 anos só para a cidade de fazer porque
ela está totalmente em estado de sítio
toda destruída e sem mais forma de vida
porque ela não tem mais saneamento
básico não tem mais hospitais escolas
aqui algumas imagens que é foi foram
feitas pelos bomba por bombardeios que o
governo de bashar al assad que governa a
síria tem duas aliadas a rússia ea
polônia
quem é um dos oponentes do governo de
bashar al assad é o iraty que ele recebe
apoio com armamentos dos estados unidos
quando eles quando eles ficam sem armas
e pra eles eles lutarem eles com eles
fazem ao momento caseiro então como um
conjunto de gás à onu o que é a onu a
onu organização das nações unidas quando
tem alguma alguma guerra ela manda
comboios lar a tentar retirar esses
habitantes que estão ainda naquele país
e remédios para quem não conseguiu sair
para eles conseguirem terão alguma
chance que a gente pode fazer para
ajudar
a primeira-ministra alemã é ela deixou
alguns refugiados alguns refugiados
alguns habitantes que eles foram saindo
para os outros países indo indo tentasse
se abrigar nos outros países porque eles
não querem ficar naquele naquele país
too guerra então ao foi uma dessas
situações foi na alemanha que a primeira
ministra ela ele deixou alguns deles
entrarem porque era o número era muito
mas muito grande que a alemanha não
tinha como é abrigá-lo abrigar todos
eles
então o que eu não consegui lá deixou
eles ficaram por alguns dias é tomando
banho dormindo e depois ela pagou o
transporte para ele está eles irem pra
algum para outros países
para ele constitui ele para que eles
consigam se repatriar o que a gente pode
ajudar o que a gente pode fazer pra
ajudar um refugiado há muitos refugiados
aqui no brasil e há muitos que devem
estar à venda enquanto eu estou falando
aqui e a gente pode ajudar acolhendo
eles deixando eles ficarem aqui dentro
isso muito obrigado e até a próxima